welcome to ear biscuits today at the
round table of dim lighting it's us say
me Lee and me rest
it's been a while since we've your
biscuit it and here we are doing it with
a video component yes for those of you
who are just listening to this ear
biscuit you would be in the know if you
were watching the video version you
would know that I have on a hoodie a
link has on plaid shirt and I'm drinking
I'm also drinking well from a mug I'm
drinking a beverage a Dr Pepper beverage
not a sponsor I'm drinking some sort of
grapefruit thing to turn my crank my
knob a little bit there we go turn up my
volume that our euphemism flow I think I
just wanted to hear all of us a little
bit get out there okay how's that sound
rolling the audio on this in here is for
us that has nothing to do with with your
listening abilities of the quality of
your listening experience yes so there
was quite a break between season 2 and
season 3 of ear biscuits but we are back
and yes we're bringing you the audio and
video experience and and we're doing
this every Monday morning now yes so
this is coming up doing this on Monday
morning but know you can receive it into
your ears and also not your eyes
although we are not going to change it
to eye biscuits because that sounds like
a Apple product that got shelved it
sounds like a it sounds like a problem
like something you need to see the
doctor about yeah doctor I can't get rid
of these eye Biskit sounds like
something you wake up with of course
your biscuits kind of seem like that -
I've always thought that I'd wax I've
always thought that it was just wax wax
it comes out and like a sandwich but
it's not an ear biscuit is a is an audio
waveform file that we create that then
we upload to the Internet's and then you
find different in various ways to impute
it into your brain I don't think we need
to tell people what it is accepted like
what we intend to do with I thought I
was going to explain
how podcasts work I thought that's what
this was this first one was about it was
all about how podcasts work isn't that
the subject today no okay that's not the
subject today but we're just gonna talk
to each other yeah I mean that's the
plan right before for this is we're
gonna speak to one another let's speak
to one another good right I just I like
speaking to you speaking to one another
now if we don't do enough of that on the
internet if you enjoyed the first couple
of seasons of and I in listen I'm gonna
have to figure out which camera I'm
gonna look at I'm just gonna look at
whatever camera feels natural
or maybe just look at you I'm gonna just
look up well if you're talking to me
look at me and if you're talking to I'm
talking to the listener to the listener
right now listener if you enjoyed season
one and two of ear biscuits you know
that usually what we did is we brought
in a guest they were often an Internet
star of some sort and they signed this
table and we kind of drilled them with
some questions and took you on a journey
into their lives and some people cried
sometimes that was unexpected
well except we tried to get it to happen
and that is going to happen on season
three but season three is going to be a
little bit different in that more in
varied things will happen on season
three so sometimes we'll talk to each
other sometimes we'll talk to somebody
from the internet somebody what
sometimes we'll just talk to somebody
that interests us well and I don't want
to say all this we don't know what we're
gonna do we're gonna do and then may
holding it all very loosely look like a
baby like a baby bird that has fallen
other than this you're gonna hold it
tight you want to hold it loosen you
want to let it fly right back up to the
mom but I can't fly yet you got it you
got it trash it and because once you
once you touch it the mom is going to
reject it actually that's not true then
you miss as a myth it's a myth it's a
myth but you are touching it you were
just touching it lightly so the analogy
doesn't work
once you touch it but if once you touch
it heavily then the mama won't take it
back it's actually a myth are you saying
it's a minute if a baby bird falls out
of the moms nest touch it lightly but do
put it back because it will not be
rejected that's a myth I'm not a hundred
percent sure that's why we have an
Internet
connection here link and you look that
up and confirm because facts are gonna
be important and it hasn't been
important before but in season three of
ear biscuits facts are important if you
touch a baby bird will its mom abandon
it what why are there so many words when
all I need is a yes
yes or no I mean the reason why many a
distillation link wrote a whole article
is because of these ads 31 adorable
slang terms for sex from the last 600
years it's quite a diversion what's the
answer
there's a wire above Manhattan that
you've probably never noticed you're
getting distracted by the side articles
right now and all we need is a fact
check man best breakfast spot in all 50
states what is that is that what just
Denny's Doctor Strange is bleeding well
I got a click on hold on is it the
different breakfast spots in all 50
states or is it one place that you can
go to all 50 states like Cracker Barrell
or Denny's these days I feel bad about
that
and by that I think they mean touching a
baby bird it turns out my mom is full of
baloney please answer the question
your mom is full of baloney yep it's not
it as a myth you can touch a baby bird
yeah I didn't read the article but from
that one thing about where they said
baloney I think that's what it so facts
are really important and we think based
on just one website that is a myth you
can touch a baby bird but back to the
analogy we're gonna hold the baby bird
that is our podcast called ear biscuits
and I can explain all the podcast works
but I'm not going to because you
probably already know and maybe you're
not interested in that's not why you're
here but we're gonna hold it lightly and
we're gonna bring it right back up to
the nest and the nest is your ear or
maybe you you know wherever you
typically let podcast into your body I
feel like I'm gonna talk less now that
we have video because I rest easy
knowing that like my exasperated look
for that whole tirade is not anything
that I need to vie for Yeah right yeah
you got all the attention you needed
what I was doing that look I didn't but
I do
you should also hold other other human
babies lightly that aren't your own
unless you're trying to keep them out of
a wolf mouth or something like that then
hold the grip advice you don't want to
let a amyl tick
vice-grip it but who knows what all
we're gonna try here at the round table
of dim lighting so I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna put a finite ending on the on the
list I'm gonna leave in ellipses guys
you know dot anodized yeah right
I think at least for this podcast the
general principle is there are things
that and we said this before we said
this in context of good mythical more
but I'll say here to there there are
things that we find ourselves talking
about it's like yeah let's save it or as
much as we talk to each other there's
still other things we can talk about
right there's always something to talk
about like what happened in the car the
other day when we left for lunch and we
were driving across
Burbank you want to you want to tell
them about that I think we should tell
that was the kind of thing that we would
keep to ourselves so cuz you take to our
graves well we almost got in a car
accident it wasn't my fault was my fault
I was drivin but then we got we almost
got in an altercation there was a little
bit of alcohol it simulated road rage
okay
maybe on someone's part maybe mine okay
and you a few minutes later after the
whole thing resolved in in whatever way
we will expire at an opinion about the
way you had an opinion about it what can
I let this kid the set up but then we
had to get to where we were going to do
what we were doing which I don't even
remember what that was who cares of this
book even cares right we're just going
from point A to point B could fill in
the blank with whatever it is and we
never came back to fully discussing what
happened and I I think that they should
now we can have the listener or the
watcher and listener go be a sinner the
winner can be a part of this or the
watcher
I like the winner listeners and Watchers
welcome wishing us okay so since you're
driving you're gonna start I've been in
quietly quite a lot of traffic things
have happened lately yeah you know I
told the story on good mythical more
about the wreck that I was in when you
were rear end it was rearing it wasn't
my fault but this situation was my fault
it was one of those situations where I
didn't know
what lane I should be in to turn and I
was kind of stalling out we were kind of
waiting for like what you were looking
at the GPS oh yeah I was waiting for the
GPS to update to tell me which direction
to go and I kind of slowed down and
moved over and it was a guy behind me
who got very frustrated with me and then
it looked like how about a ticket left
yeah I didn't know any of this was
happening it looked like I was about to
take a left and then I didn't and I got
right back in the lane and kept going
but bye-bye it looked like you were
going to take a left I think what you
mean is at the intersection you were in
the left turn lane and you had your left
turn signal yeah yeah I was giving every
indication was that I was gonna turn on
oh why it looked like maybe a little bit
I was gonna take a left basically every
single way right you even started to
take a look but I act him in my defense
I did not have my left arm out the
window pointing left which who had been
the additional key that would have been
definitely confirming the fact that I
was going left if you were on a bike I
didn't yell out hey I'm turning left I
didn't I mean I could it could have been
wrong if you're on my left but tip his
word yes this guy's turning left and
then I decided not his turn left and I
decided to pull right back out into the
the regular road and that was when I
pulled in front of a guy who and I did
again I didn't see first I just tried to
clear my nose I clear my airway but I'm
totally I can't hear anything right now
because I tried to equalize what are you
a diver you're a man who's nearly at sea
level in the air and you're like I was
trying to equalize what for we haven't
changed altitude in the past five hours
why are you suddenly trying to equalize
it because you do this often I've done
it over the past week because of the
head collab oh okay that's not that's
not really equalizing what maybe it is I
don't know oh my goodness hold that bird
turned my notch notch my turn you'll
love it
you want to uh I I'm in the I'm floating
okay so is that better yeah I'm gonna
live with this okay Wow
that was interesting I didn't mean to
derail your story did you see me grab my
nose in the middle are you talking I was
intentionally not looking at you well
see if you if you if you weren't
listening to so
if you were watching the wine is now
equalized for those of you I'm actually
not worried about it but I'm just gonna
I think over time as link is not
equalized but we have turned the volume
up in his headphone here literally okay
yeah it's like a balloon that's slowly
slowly deflating and now I did not have
any purview to what was happening and I
didn't use that word right but I didn't
in view anything that happened it made
sense in context the mirrors weren't for
me they're for you so the first thing I
know is that you're swerving back a
little bit and I I do hear a honk and
the car does not come by so no one
zoomed by you so I just had to assume
the guy was still behind us right I
never looked back but at that moment if
I'm gonna go back to that place I don't
know what it was but in that moment I
just I was instantly angry like I was
legitimately angry that he honked the
horn at you hmm
you might have a problem and I I think
what I said was I don't I don't remember
what I said to you you even know that I
had I know I know I knew that you'd
sorted a little bit but what I said was
like like he's never made a traffic
mistake well and I said that you and
then we pull up to the we were at the
light it was like another block and
that's all I said it's like it like he's
never made a Miss like what what what
right does he have to blow the horn well
let's just get to the part where you
begin asking him those questions because
what I don't know what it is that in
that moment of I don't know if it was
strength or weakness or just feeble
mindedness but I was just angry I just
felt like I don't know if it was defense
for a friend well and you felt all I
know is that I saw him get out from
behind me as we were pulling up to the
light and he pulled beside us and that
was when link rolled down his window and
well my window as he was coming by and I
braced myself a little bit tell him what
you tell him what you said link I had
made up my mind that if when we get up
to this light he pulls up beside us and
has something to say I'm gonna say
something back to a
cuz I'm mad at this guy I just don't
he's I'm sure he's made a mistake too
not currently but it's somewhere in his
life at some point in his life he's made
a traffic mistake this is a great
strategy and I don't know I just felt I
felt feisty I noticed I just felt I was
like itching fur I don't know but he
started punched he started he was like I
I did not say the first word you exactly
what it's like but I rolled the window
down it was like what now he didn't pull
right beside us he pulled a half a car
length in front and then he looked he
was he was a 45 away he was a 45 degree
angle to me on my side what he was like
was now what and then he said what's up
are you looking at what do you want but
what was the blank was was a wordy dird
was it the end it was the f-word really
and I'm not talking about Frankie
Frankie he no I'm not and he was clearly
mad he was you instigate basically you
instigated he was mad already but when
you roll down the window he was like he
was ready he was the kind of guy who is
ready for the window roll and is in it
when he was mad as it has his
catchphrase he was mad but it turns out
so was I and that's when you said an
interesting tactic but I said I'm trying
to move exactly how I said it I think I
said have you never done anything wrong
before have you never messed up and just
like that yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not
proud of it and I think as we analyze
this I will be penitent and I'll say you
know what I shouldn't have done any of
this and I'm not bragging but I do think
it's funny that I did this is definitely
funny dupit but but I thought that well
I that's what I said and then he's like
well you shouldn't be driving like
basically the I'm paraphrasing at this
point but you shouldn't be driving like
that you're an idiot and then that's
when I said well actually and I and let
me just say I said it just like this
well actually that loud
well actually I'm the idiot because I'm
the one who's driving you should be
yelling at me and I thought that was a
great tactic but then you pick
- right back up and I was like because
he didn't answer my question
I was like have you never made a traffic
mistake and he said why why are you
upset or something like that he was like
why are you so upset or why are you
yelling and I'm like and he was kind of
yelling and then I was like I'm just
matching your level which I guess wasn't
true it was it was true he yelled first
right
I was just matching his level but that's
not the kind of thing you say in a in a
in an argument like that
I was just matching your love I'm just
matching your level man like what how
does it what is that what does that
accomplish babe it was my reason I mean
what I so it wasn't what I'll say now
and what I said after the after I think
what happened was he was like why is
this guy saying these kinds of things to
me this is not the kind of road rage
argument that I typically get into he's
questioning my past and now he's
questioning he's matching my level and
he's pointing that out to me you're like
having a meta conversation in the middle
of a road rage argument and I didn't
think I would be but you're yelling that
while you're doing this in this
embarrassed to talk about it later but I
thought it would be better reliving it I
thought I would thought better by this
point in retelling the story I would
have found a way to be the hero well hey
man listen what about this are you guys
living it I'm taking up for you man no I
appreciate you doing it even though I
don't really feel like that's what was
happening I think you just were if I
seen you or like I want to yell at this
dude I want to see what happens see
where this goes you'd like to experiment
with that like you'd like to push
people's buttons you've always been that
way and I and I was very entertained by
it and my tactic was to take this you
should be yelling at me because I'm the
one who did it
I'm the idiot because I thought that was
funny to see things now but then as and
I will admit there so there was a part
of me maybe 50% of my motivation was
entertainment entertainment yeah and the
other 50% was yet the mode the first
thing was I
angry because I just don't feel like I
felt like we should extend grace to
everyone on the road because we've all
been there and it just I don't know
something in that honk said I've never
done this before how could you do this
this that was so stupid
it wasn't life-or-death no it was just a
corrective honk I mean I I accept the
honk I think the honk was appropriate
and I accepted it because I would issue
a honk in that situation not I wouldn't
issue the bird I wouldn't unleash the
bird and let it fly but I would hold it
loosely if it fell out of the nest
though but but I but if you if you've
been pulled up at the next intersection
next to the guy I don't know well you
wouldn't have your window rolled down
I don't you wouldn't be glaring I never
do that I done never instigate cuz you
never know if they've got a gun if
they're crazy I mean this is Los Angeles
you just don't you don't want to mess
with people well I could tell that he
was he was generally a peaceful person
well let's go listen I know why I know
and I know why cuz we talked about this
but let me just I'll give you I'll give
the people my assessment on this one
because I already gave it to you and
that was I think that the way to handle
that situation is if you want to enjoy
before you say it because it's funny the
way it came out because it happened and
let's say how the guy drove off the last
thing that was said he just kind of like
shook his head in disbelief and then the
light turned green he went in front of
us right and he was gone basically and
we didn't immediately start talking
about it it took a little while we went
we went a mile or so and then you're
like it's like you were deciding when
would be the best time to bring up your
assessment I thought it was a teachable
moment and so I said III I said you know
I think you could have handled that
better and and here's what I think you
could have done I think that you could
have said exactly the same words ya
changed nothing and just set it in this
tone right here and when someone is
yelling at you and then you're talking
to them like this it makes them so angry
now I'm not saying the idea is to make
them angry but if you want to if you
wanted one up this Winterson if you
your argument if that you really want to
be entertained and we all let argument
you don't let them get in your crawl
right you don't lose control you don't
match his level man that's precisely
what you don't you don't match the level
right there's no power and then you
maintain control and if you had a said
if you had a slowly roll down your
window and just kind of slyly looked
over and been like what you've never
made a mistake before he would have been
like anyway and then he would probably
put his tail between his legs and draw
me I had the right thought but I had the
wrong execution you gotta keep tryin
sacked Lee right you gotta keep
practicing you gotta gotta practicing
and when you said that I was just like
mmm yeah you're right man I just I
thought I knew that I would learn
something by doing it and I get what and
where I will give you credit is I
wouldn't have done it at all I learned
sign I wouldn't have rolled down the
window to begin with so at least you
roll down the window but it seems like
you already knew it I don't know what
you would have learned you just would
have felt good by getting getting that
guys I think maybe we could work as a
tag team and maybe you're the one who
rolled it rolls down the window and I'm
the one who does the talking it's like
maybe maybe that's the system that we
need to employ when you told me what you
when you gave your assessment the first
thing I thought was back in high school
that time when I when I scored two goals
in one soccer match yeah with my left
foot right the first and second goal I'd
ever scored in like a soccer career cuz
always played defense I'm talking like
even through a recreation I never scored
a goal in high school here I'm schooling
in one game and I'm like it's like I
just won the World Cup I did everything
but take my shirt off and you know skid
across the tub I just like this is like
I'd like it's like I had won the lottery
yeah I mean everyone in the stands
thought that he'd probably gone berserk
people had stopped cheering and you were
still running and Josh young who was the
striker mm-hm and I he scored frequently
yeah in many ways yep he comes up to me
once I go back and we're setting up to
keep playing the game and he's like
you know next time you should act like
you meant to do it right it's like like
you're before act like you've been there
but like you're not surprised that you
scored these girls act like you've been
there because you get if you keep your
cool then you will be cool now we're
gonna continue this in a second because
I do want to talk about why you felt
safe
yes engaging with this guy I think you
get us into some pretty interesting
conversation but first we're gonna pause
to let you know that this episode is
brought to you by audible audible
includes an unmatched selection of
audiobooks shows news comedy and more
from your leading publishers
broadcasters and entertainers
okay now audible is offering you a free
audiobook with a 30-day trial membership
just go to audible.com slash ear
biscuits and browse the unmatched
selection of audio programs download a
free title and start listening it's that
easy and now I have a recommendation
okay this is one of the best audiobooks
that I've ever listened to for a number
of reasons it is called the war of art
it's by Steven Pressfield the war of art
this thing is I think it's like just shy
of three hours long so you know like
easy road trip material a couple of
commutes or whatever depending on where
you live I listen to part of it with you
when we were coming back for some if you
work if you are trying to accomplish
anything creative at all and you have
that what he calls the resistance
there's so many things that can be the
resistance when you're trying to
accomplish something creative and that's
what the war of art is is overcoming
that resistance and it has it was very
very instrumental for us I read it you
listen to a little bit but we kind of
applied the principles together for kind
of getting through those tough creative
times where you feel like you don't have
anything in all the distractions that
get in the way of creating great things
so that is my recommendation so take us
up on that offer at audible.com slash
ear biscuits and if you haven't listened
before go check out the war of art and
also we're very soon gonna record the
audible version of our book the book of
mythicality is available for pre-order
both the audio
and text version now that's right
so go to audible.com slash ear biscuits
that's audible.com slash ear biscuits
and get started today
okay so yeah so finish what you're
saying about the why you felt safe
because I know I know where you're going
with this I made my mind up that if he
came by was wonder where I was gonna be
ready to pounce but I felt safe doing
that because he was in like a he was in
like a Prius that had a business
plastered on the side of it a car rap
and it was a car rap and it said eco
something or like green partners or
something like that it was like a go
something it was an eco-friendly like
company and I was like this guy's a
lovin loving it yeah tree hugger not a
tree chopper right you know so I felt I
assessed him and his vehicle very
quickly and was like alright I'm going
in on this right and interestingly I was
right he was cool because this okay this
is a principal lot more than me this is
a principal I'd like to dig into and
that is this idea of you feel like you
know something about someone because of
the car that they drive okay thinking
about this because it has gotten a
little personal for me because you
haven't seen this but I am currently
driving a convertible white Mustang
seriously yeah and I'm it's not mine I'm
renting it in here so you know I was in
the I was in the accident in my car and
I know you can just say you wanted to
rent a no Mustang
oh yeah I don't have to have a reason
well well I have a reason why I was
running but I'll tell you exactly why I
picked this car and how it makes me feel
about myself so I was in the accident
and there was very little damage but
there wasn't like sensor damage on the
back of the car and I think the bumpers
a little bit messed up so it's in the
shop you know you know my insurance
gives me an allowance for a rental car
now I do this on a fairly regular basis
like if I have to rent a car a wife
gives me a
if a car if my car's being worked on or
we're traveling or whatever when I go
into the place they're like what would
you like and I'm like do you have
anything interesting because you know
you know me you know my personality my
personality is knew shy I want something
that's new I don't want to get into the
Chevy Malibu you know what I'm saying
that's not be an interesting choice
I want to just I want to get into
something this ring first of all though
the woman says no lie she's like we have
a minivan that would be interesting for
you to think that that's what I would
think is interesting like I mean link
knows that life very well I've been I've
been and I've been in the minivan it's
not interesting that's not my idea of a
good time you know kind of its kind of
anti interesting right that's the whole
point
I mean it's spacious if by interesting
she means like capable of haul and lots
of kids that's interesting then that's
an interesting definition of interest
but she said okay other than that we
have a Camaro and also okay now we're
talking now we're talking
I mean all the kids that I knew in high
school that drove Camaros were cool that
well they were interesting yeah and it
was very interesting he says but I think
you'll actually fit better in our ragtop
Mustang and I was like cha-ching yes sir
show me the keys so you're you were most
interested in the keys well the keys are
the key to starting the car
well maybe button is it a push button
push button okay she'll ride the button
high tech well you got to have the key
fob they call it to hit the button
you know how cars work do you want to
talk about how cop cars would add that
to the help podcast work but you
actually don't know how cars work no I
don't care how they work right if they
work so I'm calling you on that way so
yeah tell me how cars work so it's our
internal combustion I mean I could tell
you but the carburetor do so I get into
I get into this convertible and this
place was just a couple of blocks from
the studio right so I get into the
convertible ragtop down all rain and
he's like he's in there showing me how
stuff works he's like you want you want
it down I'm like yeah I've got to go two
blocks but I'm gonna go two blocks and
style and so as you can imagine I'm a
large man I'm very tall I have very high
hair so I noticed very quickly as soon
as I pulled out into traffic that my
hair is basically above the windshield
so it is wind shear is just right there
it hits me right there so my hair is
like vibrating you think it might get
sheared off yeah I don't think I'm gonna
lose it but I know that my it's gonna
change the shape of my cut you know what
I mean gonna be windblown what you go
ahead go into convenience store it's
gonna ruin your your rep but I was very
self-conscious about being in this white
convertible because I was started to
think about what I would think if I saw
a dude who looks like me in a white
convertible with the top down yeah by
the way no sunglasses at the time
because I left him in the other car so
you're squinting so I'm just I look like
a complete noob you know sunny
California convertible no sunglasses too
big for the thing hey wind sheared
constantly I mean you've got burbank
tourists written all over you okay yeah
but here's what I'll own you're on a
business trip well everything that I
could think about what I would think
about me was was negative right it was
like this guy was in one commercial one
time you know that was one of the things
I was thinking this guy was like in a
restless legs pharmaceutical commercial
you know one of those things both legs
Treece treats restless legs but gives
you seizures kind of thing and it was
just one leg by the way Hey well no it's
restless legs leg syndrome but it could
be I have it actually and I get it in
both legs but you weren't in the ad no
but that's the kind of person that I
looked like a guy who has like too much
hair for his own good and it's blowing
in the wind and hey he looks like he
could have been in a commercial one time
you could but it wasn't a great
commercial and he doesn't have a come
here could real career cuz he's in a
Mustang and he's in a white Mustang and
he's in like the not the nice model I
must think he's in like the low
horsepower model of Mustang that the
four cylinder that they use for her
rental krill companies I I think you
could look like the adopted son of a
auto repair man who
he asked him to like take the car for a
spin to make sure that the repairs are
work who took okay that's it that's it
that is interesting isn't it itself
that's what I think you are but this
whole idea of coming to a conclusion
about somebody because of the vehicle
that they're in which first of all that
is a that's human it's well it's very
human but it's also the kind of thing
that is would be very difficult for a
caveman to understand you know one day
there's going to be this thing that
people get inside of and go around and
you're going to be able to make
inferences about their lifestyle based
on what they're in he's gonna be like oh
you know I probably won't I've seen any
of it cuz he doesn't speak English but
what about but even the concept would be
foreign to him but what about the cars
that we're actually in I mean you does
this this should also apply to what
people think of it applies actually well
what what I kind of concluded is like is
there anyone out there who just thinks
that I'm a guy who's getting his car
repaired and just wants to have a little
fun no no one thinks that well that's
the truth because no one is going
because you want to think the thing that
is like judging people the hardest right
that's the guy from the restless legs
commercial yeah that's the guy whose dad
just worked on a vehicle and he's making
sure the repairs took which is what your
yeah I I think that's likely but by to
go but he's like that's just a dude is
getting his car worked on and asked for
something interesting would you feel
freer because I mean you're gonna leave
tonight you're gonna get in this thing
tomorrow in the broad daylight you're
gonna pick me up at my house I'll be
wearing a sunglass we're gonna come in
together yeah I don't know how I feel
about that you want her to mete out the
times it's impacting me I've already
thought about it I've actually been
thinking about picking you up in it no
I've been falling is gonna be he's gonna
love I actually was a little bit it the
fact that I had to park on the street
today because of what they were shooting
out in the parking lot you know I knew
you didn't see it and I and I didn't I
almost don't want to talk about this
tonight because just a surprise because
I wanted to roll
up and - and pick you up I'd be like you
bought me a convertible yeah and you
know I rented it and let me tell you the
whole riding down the the the highway
the freeway it top speeds with the top
down especially with my height is I've
kind of especially without sunglasses I
kind of felt like things were about to
get in my eye
you could go so you're loud it's so loud
- geese get it also makes you feel lying
in the Hudson it makes you feel unsafe
not because you feel like you could roll
over and like get your head cut off but
it just may it's like the reality of
these big loud fast machines moving all
around you is really you're so immediate
when you're in a convertible you know
and that none of it none of that sounds
good to me but I'm gonna withhold
judgment till in the morning but it's
interesting it is interesting I mean
this is Southern California man you got
to have that convertible experience but
would you feel more free if we took a
sheet of paper and this was sharpie just
wrote on it rental my car no no no you
can't say rental cuz then it seems like
you're a tourist you got to say car's in
the shop
minor damage just wanted something
interest just wanted something
interesting that wasn't a minivan
wouldn't have picked white but it is all
they had it's quite a sign it's gonna be
a piece of poster board going to sheets
and what do I win that I put that I put
it on the back every side guy I don't
think I'm gonna be comfortable right
over the unless there's one I got every
night on every side gotta wrap it or we
can wrap the thing and it could say like
eco something and then it's like oh I
get it
they're targets those guys work for an
eco company they're selling solar to
people but okay but the funny thing is
is that this happened to me earlier this
week what had nothing to do with the car
this is before I took the car in and I I
was walking to my car that wasn't yet in
the shop and I had you know which says
what about you
what you're getting at no no what your
no I don't wanna move them beyond cars
I'm getting a little bit more personal
okay about a tire at this point not a
tire of a car but clothing and that is
okay so we both have these are you
renting right now right like the jewelry
collars well they're pants with elastic
at the bottom there these pants you know
I would never jog you know they're like
they're kind of like Bieber like Bieber
was wearing these pants like eight years
ago right and I mean it's and it's got a
string there drawstring we actually both
have a pair on right now it's kind of
got like a little bit of a drop crotch
and then you've got like the tight the
tight calves or whatever and there's
like this fake like bunching that
happens so we both have a pair of these
and I don't like the string because you
have to move it out of the way when you
go number one I have to like hold all
the string I feel like it's like I'm
gathering ducklings or something every
time I'm trying to use the restroom
okay well that's another discussion we
can have I can show you how to watch it
what to do with the strings you like my
dad anyway so you got to be like my dad
so it's a teachable moment I'll tell you
I'll tell you about this where to put
the strings later
so we've both got a pair a couple of
pairs it just tell me where you put the
strings and just do it
well I don't gather them like ducklings
I just untie them and then they just
sort of naturally go into one hand I
just sort of grab them both with one
hand and then I just drop drawer drop
drawer and then do my business you had a
point I don't think about it that much
and I also had on one of these shirts
probably peeing all over them I got one
of these shirts that's kind of like like
it's a longer t-shirt yeah you know what
I'm saying like it's like longer than it
probably should be but it's also kind of
in style in some circles and so I and
then I've gotten my like my my Jordans
you know I like I got a few Jordan ones
that I wear and I and I like not
bragging I just got them I'm walking to
my car no this isn't about bragging this
is about being self-conscious this is
where this is going okay I'm walking to
my car you know having just said goodbye
to my wife and children 39 year old man
and I kind of just look down at
feet and I'm like I got these Jordans on
I got these Bieber pants on and I got
this but really what is like a Bieber
shirt in a lot of ways not like Bieber
now but like Bieber a couple of years
ago yeah and I'm like what am I doing
with my life and then I'm like what
would I think of me if I saw me mm-hmm
and then it's same exact thing again I
was like I would be like who is this guy
that was in the restless legs commercial
one time and he made a little money and
now he went he's riding he saw an
article with Justin Bieber in it and he
saw him with some long t-shirt on and
some drop crotch pants and a Air Jordans
he was like I won't dressed like that
even though I'm about to turn 40 yeah
now I could have gone back inside and
changed I was like I don't care really
changing of what like a shorter shirt
like a normal t-shirt mmm yeah but it
didn't just hit me I was like I I mean
I'm wearing that I think I'm wearing
this stuff just because you go to the
places where you that you buy clothes
and I'm like oh this fits I like it's
like fashion and somebody has determined
that this is in style
right yeah and and so I'm not gonna I'm
know who am I to argue with that
I'm just gonna I'm gonna wear that I've
had this shirt that I have on right now
a long time for freaking at least a
decade let's really think about this I
can't remember wearing this shirt when
we shot the pilot to commercial Kings is
that 10 years ago no the pilot of
commercial Kings was 7 year 2010 yeah
2011 I have had a 10 year but you've had
it 10 years but it was hanging in a rack
in there now I was cold and I had it I
just had a t-shirt there's just plaid
shirt cuz I'm not yeah it's like it's
it's it's gonna be ok but just the
copyin choice I like buying new stuff
that's like I like fashion you know you
can't fault you for that I don't think
you're necessarily pretending it's well
I think you are but you wouldn't
necessarily be but if I saw you and I
didn't know use not pretending it's
you make choices to put on you put
things on your body to put clothing on
your body because you think a certain
thing about yourself and you want other
people to think a certain thing about
you I do that every single morning I
think about what I'm gonna what I what
I'm gonna wear
based on what I need to do and who I'm
gonna see well you sound like a like a
repairman like I'm gonna I'm gonna go
into the hole today I got my rubber
boots on well it's like I feel like
we're just writing today I want to be
more comfortable I'm definitely dropping
the crotch
I'm into that I will say that the drop
crotch is super comfortable and I feel
like it's helping my back so there's a
there's some functionality there because
it because it's so loose everything is
so loose and it's like loose it's loose
around your hips and stuff but I'm
healthy at this I've got this meeting
today where I like I feel like I'm gonna
be opinionated
and I I want my opinions to matter so
what are you gonna wear so I might
button the top I'm gonna wear a button
shirt and I might button the top button
well what is the budding again like
wearing a t-shirt and I don't button the
top but I don't want to wear a t-shirt
because I'm because of what it might say
about me because the t-shirts just like
Boyle wear a t-shirt a boy who are you
sure but if a man with an opinion is
gonna wear buttons buttons mean business
buttons mean business and the top button
means a lot of business but I better put
on a hat to balance it because I'm not
an old man meaning business I'm a young
man meaning business I've I don't I
don't necessarily think about all of
those thoughts but those are the
thoughts in general that make me
button up hat up crotch down whatever
the case may be and I and sometimes I'm
like you know what I don't feel really
happy this morning I just need to I need
to put on my happy shirt what you have a
happy shirt you know that sweatshirt
that has like the the wolf on it that
looks like the guy who came to put the
like piece of delivery man came to the
door I open the door and he was there oh
he was mesmerized by CS on your shirt I
see a snake on your shirt are you now
has like the code of what that got
responded to it that made me happy so
now when I put on the shirt and I I have
confidence that I don't know it gives me
more common into that delivery guy again
he's gonna love this shirt
that's my happy shirt yeah yeah I feel
like it
IIIi want the day to I gotta be really
extra happy today now I don't listen I
don't fault you because I've already
explained that I do the same exact thing
you know I'm I'm I am thinking about
what people are going to think about me
based on the clothing choices that I
make but let me just say that I think
it's got a little sad it's okay you know
you've got guys like you know Steve Jobs
was like the quintessential example of
this like Dennis the Menace there are
lots of really successful people who say
that having an outfit having the Dennis
the Menace every single day you wear the
same thing the reason that those people
made that decision is because they
didn't want to make that decision every
single day right they so many important
decisions to make right I've got so many
things to worry about
I'm gonna just hey this is this is what
my wardrobe is and some people might
vary it up a little bit some people are
like I've got white shirts black shirts
and grey shirts but they're all
basically the same and I'm not making
any decisions about who I'm gonna see
they just know that that's linked and he
wears a black shirt and white pants
after Labor Day maybe we got a friend
who just wears a white t-shirt a white
v-neck t-shirt every day of his life who
Jesse not your wife he wears a white
t-shirt every day of his life
he does think back you've never seen him
wear anything but a white t-shirt he
thought about he has made that decision
and we know it you you've seen you
you've I know anymore yeah so you've had
more I've had a conversation with him
about it and it is that his reasoning
that's his reasoning he streamlined it
he doesn't want to make that decision he
also doesn't like to wear shoes or socks
a lot either now and I could be you
would never be that guy you would never
be the Steve Jobs no uniform guy no but
but I could be right really a
feels to me though it appeals to you
know okay cuz you can't think they did
good because there's a no because
there's competing forces here so you
want to be this one
one competing one force is my desire for
change right and my desire for nationís
yeah and the and the other desire is my
desire for doing something that I think
is something of benefit to me and is
like that's a really cool idea that's a
cool new idea so when I heard that idea
of wearing the same thing every day
that was the newness that intrigued me
right yeah yeah then I was like I can't
do that because we we shoot good
mythical morning and you know if we if
we happen to wear the same shirt too
close between two episodes people
pointed out you know well it isn't it's
the it's the key thing that people want
to comment on I mean if you wore the
same thing every day what would people
comment about nothing there's nothing
else to comment about right and it
wouldn't be like it was a daily show it
would be like these guys sat down and
recorded a year's worth of shows and
they had a couple of days so but then it
dawned on you that the freshness of
experiencing a new outfit every day is
more important to you than than some
sort of efficiency I think but I could
fall for that but I think there are I
think there is every reason I let me
just say this I think there is only good
reasons for picking one outfit it's more
economical are you applying that for
like a like a principle of a private
school there's no no no no no yeah this
is basically this is all what you're
getting at we're this episode has been
paid for by a private school that you
look normal or uniform coming we're
trying to teach the kids that uniforms
make sense but no there's a reason that
uniforms make sense that's cool we're
not gonna get into that button so you've
got it's economical you don't you that
whole thing that we just talked about
this whole self conscious thing of like
am I gonna be judged for what I'm
wearing
you can't completely eliminate that
because you're like doesn't matter what
this guy's got going on that day he
wears exactly the same thing it takes
out that extra decision so that you have
the brain
power to put it in other places but it
also kind of is just sort of this I'm
making a statement that I'm not giving
in to this idea that I am what I
externally applied to myself that seems
healthy that all seems great right now
but you lose some things as well yeah
like why don't you also just shave your
head you know don't worry about that I
mean because their self-expression
involved absolutely I mean it you know
you got a you got to be able to express
yourself mean like how are people gonna
know that I want to be happy today if I
can never wear my happy shirt well
because then what if you just embodied
your happiness in your face that's doing
the things that you said as opposed to
the things that you wore I mean yeah we
I mean let me you got you yeah we got
the hair you got the hair is but the
hair is part of your body it's an
extension of yourself it's like it's
like an animal that has lay it's like a
peacock you know I'm saying that's like
telling the peacock did cut his feathers
off I don't want to do that the peacock
cuts his feathers off he doesn't get to
pass his genes on to the next generation
no it's like telling a snake don't keep
it your skin mmm that didn't work no it
is you know I'm not but I'm not saying
that if I cut my hair off I wouldn't be
able to pass my genes to the next
generation I've already passed my genes
to the next generation and it had
nothing to do with my hair but let's
just say because I just had basically a
buzz when I got married
you made it sound like your seed was
spread far and wide
I mean you had two children my hair is
like a dandelion if you were if you if
you blow if you blow on my hair it's it
separates and seeds get spread I don't
know how many children I've got I've got
dandelion hair that's okay I'm gonna
tell you that's how i reproduce progeny
works you have you've have spores you
have two spores but you have not like
have a whole generation I have thousands
of spores I do what are we talking about
we're talking about whether or not you
should wear different colored clothes
every single day and whether or not you
should style your hair
I think I know we were gonna have to
come down
because I'm not about to shave my head
and I'm not about to start wearing the
same thing every day so I guess oh now
we need to justify our conclusion yes we
know why we want the conclusion to be
now we need to make it seem like it's
the right thing to do but that's not
life work any form yeah any form of any
opportunity for self-expression is a
Liberty that should be granted so
subject to how it impacts other people
so I mean if you're if you're just gonna
but but you should not be defined by any
one particular way that you've expressed
yourself but you can also choose for
your form of self-expression to be that
I'm going to wear the same thing every
day that's your prerogative
right it's worked well for a lot of
people so what I'm gonna say is I'm
going to hold out the possibility that
there will come a time in which I will
wear the same thing every day
one of the happiest times in my life is
when I had a buzz when I had a buzz cut
I had a buzz and like the 7th and 8th
grade a little bit of ninth grade mm-hm
and then I had and are you saying it was
because of the buzz because I don't
think it had anything to do with the
buzz I don't recall you saying because I
was there for you every day st. man I
just loved this buzz but I did love life
it's great by us I did my hair is so
short I love the feeling of the wind in
my hair and you know I was thinking it
all the time and I love the idea of just
getting up and not having to think about
my hair
I think this convertible is messing with
you it's not like I need to have a buzz
and I need to buy that convertible a
couple of weeks from now you're not
gonna have two convertible anymore and
you're gonna have a buzz and you're
gonna feel you're not gonna feel any
wind and any hair and you're gonna be
like I shouldn't have done that what I'm
saying I gotta get a convertible again I
think that my 60s are going to be
defined by having a buzz having a really
really big bushy beard that's completely
unkempt like a Letterman beard like what
he's doing yeah and then I'm gonna have
just a suit like I think it's
it's gonna be what onesie like Oh like
I'm and maybe I'll pick an interesting
color like yellow you know it's the guy
in the yellow onesie with the buzz and
the beard that's that's gonna be me but
Nana
nice but banana man in this in my 60s a
good ten year span of that I got 20
years to plan this out I mean that's
just kind of a starting point
buzz glasses goggles because I'm gonna
be in a convertible all at all times
goggles for eye protection yeah big buzz
banana suit maybe like blue shoes like
blue high tops or something like that
and that's just who I am that's what I
do all the time
I want long braids okay like once it
gets so long and you braid it I'm
talking like Willie Nelson mm-hmm I
think you want to be David Letterman I'm
pretty sure I want to be Willie Nelson
okay you want braids and a beard a short
beard a short mmm he keeps it pretty
sure it does keep it short
no I'll go long long beard so it's like
a Rick Rubin meets willing no it's kind
of like a Weiland meets Willie Wow yes
perfect yeah Oh Whaley yes what do you
got what's your clothes gonna be
overalls no shirt underneath okay I mean
you got I might have to like but I'm in
I'm gonna I'm gonna figure out the
inside of the overalls for no chafing
it's like flan it not flannel cuz it's
hot here I'll be here I'll be in Malibu
well by that time 20 years from now
there'll be some sort of like cooling
Holly fabric Holly Fabrice self wicking
self-awakening high-tech inner lining of
overalls and by overall I mean overall
of me yeah you could probably nothing
out you could probably have a shirt on
actually like a long-sleeve shirt that's
completely clear that nobody else see 20
years from now the technology will be
out of control
why would I want a perfectly clear shirt
so you always look like you're just in a
pair of overalls but when it gets cold
you're still close you're right I'm cold
natured yeah you're lookin out for ya
other teachable moment domina we're
alone
sleeve translucent sweatshirts overalls
self wicking overalls and those boots
that I wore to Sundance because I'm
itching to wear those again yeah you
need more excuse go boots braids you
know Waylon beard banana man and Whaley
yeah coming up we're gonna look like I
mean it's not our prescription for you
you can wear whatever you want but you
can do it and if you do it before we do
it we're gonna be angry about it
so and let me just say I don't do it I
do think I do want to be very clear that
I do think that you shouldn't just pick
one thing to wear I think at least for
as long as we're selling clothing and
hoodies and t-shirts and other things
that we sell yes you definitely wear all
of that keep it real mixed up you know
you're gonna you're gonna want to wear
that stuff but when you get to your 60s
I think that's the thing yeah don't
start now but let's just all make a
commitment that when we get to our 60s
if we get to our 60s that's when we
that's when we simplify things you pick
your suit you pick your haircut you pick
your facial hair configuration and you
just roll with it until the end I'll be
banana man till I'm in the grave until
the end through the end last shot you
know what I'm gonna look like take a
picture bury me and my translucent
sweater and don't judge people based on
what they wear and keep your cool when
confronting them in a traffic situation
yeah don't be like Lee I mean you get
you didn't you know you win by keeping
your cool and you are cool by just being
who you are if that means wearing the
same thing every day or wearing
something different every day you wear
that happy shirt yeah wear your happy
shirt be happy and we're gonna bring you
another air biscuit next week Monday
first thing these things are going to
keep coming out give us your feedback on
Soundcloud in a review on iTunes or in
the comments of this YouTube video and
remember the video version of ear
biscuits is always available at
youtube.com slash this is mythical thank
you for being your mythical best
[Music]